[Applause]
[Music]
we're halfway through October and this
week's new releases are about to get a
little racy not just because of South
Park we're also gonna race with a new
Grand Turismo look I never promise that
jokes would be good but they should be
much better in South Park the fractured
but whole in the latest cardboard
cut-out RPG you'll choose from 12
superhero classes but there's not just
one hero alliance in South Park one
faction is controlled by Cartman and his
followers while the other engages in a
civil war over franchise movie rights
you can expect the same level of
irreverence humour and downright
ridiculous moments here as the landmark
TV series brings and you can Don your
cape on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Tuesday
October 17th if you can't wait until
then you can always check out our
gameplay videos including a boss battle
with some handsy priests if you prefer
something a little more grounded you
can't get much more hyper realistic than
GT sport the latest in the driving Sims
series is the first Gran Turismo on ps4
and it's making use of the current
generations love of eSports to host live
events and tournaments it's also the
series first foray into virtual reality
letting you drive in cockpit view with
the PS VR headset and if you like
Porsches it's also the first time you'll
be able to drive those GT sport comes to
ps4 on Tuesday the 17th let's move from
the race track to the ring WWE 2k 18 is
definitely bringing the Smackdown this
year with 8 man Royal Rumbles that have
been reworked with new finishers and
eliminations but perhaps the most
important edition is in the character
roster the man the myth the legend KFC's
Colonel Sanders is making his way into
the ring you can give him a try on ps4
Xbox one and PC on the 17th with a
Nintendo switch version coming later
this fall
about you but I'm turning my kernel into
the Jim Gaffigan version Esalen is
pretty classic and so is Age of Empires
now the RTS is getting a remaster
complete with 4k support brand-new
narration and rebuilt sound effects but
you can always turn all that off and
play in classic mode to the definitive
edition includes the original game and
rise of Rome expansion which means
you've got 16 civilizations and 10
campaigns to dig into if you need to
scratch that world conquering itch you
can do it with a shiny new coat of paint
on PC on Thursday the 19th or maybe you
prefer a more hands-on approach with
your infantry in that case you can jump
into the fray with Fire Emblem warriors
the minds behind dynasty Warriors are
trading chinese history for Nintendo's
strategy games which means you'll take
control of heroes from Fire Emblem fates
awakening and more and the classic
weapon triangle of axes lances and
swords still stands so you'll have to be
smart about who you send into battle you
can charge in on Nintendo switch and new
3ds on Friday the 20th and those are
some of the hottest games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more games next week